accident tragique sur l'autoroute a7 un
carambolage entre trois autocars et un
poids-lourd fait sept morts
l'un des chauffeurs d'autre qu'à rouler
trop vite tourner français action
d'orgueil de l'allemand ulrich qui gagne
l'étape d'albertville devant pantani
dopage les policiers perquisitionnent ce
soir l'autel des tv m
halberg après laffaire de l'infirmière
de mantes-la-jolie accusé d'euthanasie
enquête aux pays bas où cette pratique
est en voie d'être légalisé soudan sept
cent mille personnes au bord de la
famine l'aide humanitaire et pillé par
les factions rivales qui se livrent à
une guerre qui n'en finit pas
quant au nac a quitté la pelouse des
stades pour les plateaux de cinéma il
tourne actuellement dans la région de
lyon en compagnie de michel serrault
madame monsieur bonsoir un terrible
carambolage de nuit dernière sur
l'autoroute a7 près de montélimar qui a
fait sept morts et sept blessés graves
au départ un chauffeur de poids lourd
dans le véhicule se met en travers de la
chaussée le chauffeur s'était
apparemment endormi deux autocars en
allemand hollandais parviennent à
freiner à temps pour l'éviter
en revanche un troisième autocar qui
roulait lui trop vite les percutent
yannick aroussi hadji rares gagnants
malgré une tentative de freinage
désespéré le chauffeur de l'autocar
hollandais n'a pu éviter les autres
véhicules qui étaient arrêtées sur la
chaussée
pris dans un bouchon et ce soir les
enquêteurs se pose toujours la même
question pourquoi malgré la
signalisation du ralentissement
l'autobus hollandais est il venu
percuter violemment ce cas allemand par
l'arrière avant de finir sa course
contre notre bus un accident en deux
temps d'abord un camion dont le
chauffeur s'est endormi se couche sur la
chaussée 25 minutes plus tard et environ
800 mètres plus loin
le chauffeur du bus hollandais perd le
contrôle de son véhicule
les enquêteurs mettent en avant la
vitesse excessive
puisque sont saisies et les disques on
parlait déjà il dit 100 km heure pour
les deux premiers regards et 120 pour
l'autre sept morts neuf blessés graves
23 blessés légers voici ce soir le bilan
de l'accident le chauffeur du car
hollandais dont la femme et la fille
sont décédées et gardé à vue depuis la
fin de matinée
il devrait être mise en examen demain
dans le cadre d'une information
judiciaire pour homicide involontaire
le chauffeur du camion que l'on voit ici
devrait connaître le même sort
d'après son employeur il effectué hier
une journée de travail normale c'est
l'implication je passe n'est pas direct
c'est la fois aux bus qui roulent
beaucoup beaucoup trop mutins avec neuf
personnes à bord voilà le ministre des
transports réclament l'ouverture d'une
enquête administrative et technique le
juge d'instruction pourrait quant à lui
demandé des investigations
supplémentaires
il apparaît que le limiteur de vitesse
du quart aux landais ne fonctionnait pas
sur les 80 passagers des trois autres
quarts qui n'ont pas été trop
sérieusement blessées la plupart sont
choqués l'accident est survenu en pleine
nuit somnolait il dormait et aussitôt
une cellule de crise a mis à leur
disposition des locaux des médecins et
des psychologues
reportage virginie fichet olivier
jacquin à leur manière les enfants
rescapés du drame ont exprimé le
traumatisme de l'accident
là c'est un dessin avec des fleurs et et
l'âme des gens qui sont veulent même des
gens qui ont disparu aujourd'hui
les 80 passagers indemnes mais choquées
ont passé les premières heures de la
matinée dans la petite commune toute
proche de savasse totalement mobilisée
malgré les difficultés la communication
était difficile puisque c'étaient des
hollandais et les allemands
on ne savait pas toujours où était le
chauffeur où étaient les listes de
passagers
donc on pouvait pas les amener comme ça
d'autant que semble-t-il certains même
soit parti tout seul
d'abord murés dans leur silence ceux qui
sont arrivés jusqu'ici revivent peu à
peu cette nuit cauchemardesque
et que certaines de fois je bosse avec
moi j'essaie de vent dans le cas je
dormais et puis il ya eu un grand boum
je me suis réveillé je n'ai pas bougé je
n'ai pas réalisé ce qui se passait mon
mari a dit il faut sortir ça sent le
brûlé
il faut partir vite rapidement les
psychiatres présent encourage les
rescapés a parlé à raconter pour
surmonter la terrible réalité et éviter
tout séquelles psychologiques à cette
formidable culpabilité d'être vivant
alors que d'autres sont sont en
souffrance physique voire des cds est
donc en aidant leurs propres familles en
les rassurant en agissant par eux-mêmes
en s'entraidant entre eux en fait on
l'est on leur permet de passer ses
premières heures qui sont souvent
extrêmement pénible transféré au 45e
régiment de transmissions de montélimar
les rescapés ont ensuite attendu d'être
rapatriés dans leur pays d'origine
mais pas question pour eux de reprendre
un bus pour l'allemagne ou les pays-bas
pourrait partir en avion de lyon à
francfort et de francfort jusqu'à brême
c'est à dire ce soir vers 23 heures
ils sont tous de retour après l'ultime
épreuve le trajet en autocar jusqu'à
l'aéroport de lyon satolas avant de
retrouver enfin une sérénité toute
relative au milieu des leurs mais en
marge de cet accident la gendarmerie met
en place à l'occasion des départs en
vacances du mois d'août la semaine
prochaine dont la fin de cette semaine
par dont un nouveau système radar pour
contrôler les vitesses qui permet de
détecter les chauffards bien en amont de
l'endroit où sont installés les
gendarmes reportage eric mézil
olivier robert dans la ligne de mire des
crs des camions des bus
cette descente particulièrement
dangereuse de l'autoroute a6 se prête
donc bien en contrôle de vitesse
hier plus gros qu'un caméscope
le nouveau radar laser et la poser sur
son trépied pratique pas cher 50 mille
francs
il peut lire la vitesse de n'importe
quel véhicule à plus d'un kilomètre pour
le policier de la route
ses larmes absolution en ile-de-france
la vitesse est directement liée à plus
d'un accident sur deux et à la proche de
la capitale
le comportement des automobilistes se
transforme en force à redescendre et
pas chez papa
pour garder par tout le stade où la
droite ou la gauche a attrapé des queues
de poisson ça ça fait pas c'est la façon
de conduire qu'ils ont par ici et c'est
nous c'est vrai que nous avec nous en
vain qu'on a c'est pas toujours facile
pas facile en effet d'autant que la
majorité des conducteurs n'ont pas
conscience de mal conduits à bord de
voitures toujours plus puissantes et
apparemment plus sur les automobilistes
perdent de vue les conditions de
circulation qui les entourent lui
vitesse et densité du trafic à 3,81 jeu
on a des voitures
poussan qu'on avait une droite une
question d'argent
le comportement général et nobilis qui
ne respectent pas les consignes de
prudence élémentaire à savoir notamment
les distances de sécurité qui sont pas
respectés et la vitesse qui n'est
absolument pas adapté aux conditions
générales de ce classement
la meilleure prévention cette moindre
agression en un an le nombre d'accidents
corporels sur paris et banlieue a
augmenté de plus de 20% le tour de
france cycliste comme on les aime avec
un sursaut d'orgueil aujourd'hui entre
vizille et albertville de l'allemand jan
ullrich déposséder fière de son maillot
jaune
il a remporté l'étape au sprint juste
devant devinez qui de nouveau leader
italien pantani et il revient à la
troisième place du classement général
laurent frédéric bollée quand yann et
marco ont des choses à se dire qu'en
oulrich et pantani unissent leurs forces
ça fait mal très mal pour les autres
forcément derrière au départ de vizille
ce matin en tout cas la passation de
pouvoir a déjà eu lieu depuis la veille
marco pantani est en jaune c'est lui
désormais le patron celui qui regarde
tous les autres de haut
oui mais avec encore cinq cols à grimper
rien n'est facile aujourd'hui
ainsi dans les descentes malgré le hors
piste
il en faudrait plus pour arrêter les
coureurs question de fierté
question d'orgueil stéphane heulot le
français demi
et échapper le tour de france où la
frontière entre le mal et le lien entre
la souffrance et les bons sentiments sur
une route diabolique mais qui donne des
ailes
le col de la madeleine c'est 20
kilomètres d'ascension dit hors
catégorie totalement ali dure mais pas
pour jan ullrich qui attaquent
superbement seul marco pantani est en
mesure de répondre
c'est le duel au sommet entre les deux
monstres du peloton pantani le pirate en
danseuse oulrich lecavalier stoïque et
puissant derrière bobby holik
l'américain a décroché sa 2e place au
général est en danger car rien n'arrête
où le riche et pantani qui naissent sur
place stéphane heulot
c'est héroïque c'est splendide on se
presse on court pour admirer les deux
champions qui font parler leur place
le sommet de la madeleine ils ont deux
minutes d'avancé dans la descente où le
riche semble pédaler en accéléré
l'allemand veut récupérer la deuxième
place au général
l'arrivée est situé à albertville
ainsi olympique pour les deux médailles
d'or du jour jusqu'au bout ils sont
inséparables ils se tiennent oulrich
l'emportent finalement d'un pneu et ils
se rendent tellement hommage
oui il a très bien mérité sa victoire
finale au litige qui remonte en 3e
position au général
l'allemand devra donc encore attaqué
italien marco pantani avec son allure de
corsair est la révélation de ce tour 98
après son exploit et d'hier il est en
passe de gagner le tour de france marco
pantani est un miraculé du sport en
effet après une chute terrible en 1995
il fut tout est au lit pendant près d'un
an
incapable de marcher florent gautreau
alain poirier
c'est un pirate de la route qui dévale
les montagnes et des valises ses
adversaires ou bustier des temps
modernes
pantani est le héros que l'italie
attendait depuis gimont dix derniers
vainqueurs italien du courant 65 les
terres de la classe et du style celui
d'un grimpeurs légers comme on n'en fait
plus il ressemble à son modèle son
mentor le luxembourgeois charly gaulle 1
m 77 57 kg tout mouillé mental y fait
des bonds là où les autres reculent
comme gaulle il peut creuser des écarts
incroyable dans l'école comme gaulle ne
peut gagner le tour et dès que le petit
chauve souris
c'est du délire en italie quant à une
soigne son look crâne rasé bandana et
regard d'ange il fait le bonheur des
petits et des grands
il y alors qu'il commence à 10 n est pas
les pertes
gr quelqu'un sur un vélo seul compte
l'homme et son courage ses pantani qu'il
dit il sait de quoi il parle
champion du monde des chutes graves et
des gadins en série pantani c'est tout
cassé le pouce la clavicule et le tibia
péroné en 95 fauché par une voiture dans
la course milan turin il frôle même la
mort sa carrière est compromise
je ne pourrais pas être assez en forme
pour le giro c'est la mort dans l'âme
mais je le suivrai à la télévision mais
pantani ray suscite cette année au mois
de mai il gagne ce tour d'italie qui
n'avait jamais voulu s'offrir à lui
un tour d'italie peut être un tour de
france un tour de force italien remis au
goût du jour un panache qu'on croyait
révolues montagne en est sur le chemin
de croix même bien au paradis en marge
de la course les affaires de dopage
continue d'alimenter la chronique le
directeur sportif et le médecin d'équipé
tvm m'ont testé la mise en examen la
nuit dernière à reims mais remis en
liberté ils sont suspectés de transport
et de détention de marchandise
dangereuse autrement dit de produits
dopants mais pour l'instant il n'est pas
question comme dans l' affaire festina
d'inquiéter les coureurs qui sont
toujours sur le tout pour autant les
policiers continuent d'enquêter des
services des douanes ont perquisitionné
cet après midi sur la route d'albert vie
d'un camion de l'équipe big mat mois
lequel ils ont saisi une centaine de
boîtes de médicaments et à l'arrivée à
albertville des policiers se sont
présentés à l'hôtel de l'équipe
hollandaise tvm reportage pascal nous
c'est bon rémy pourrait céder l'étape
n'a pas été très fructueuse aujourd'hui
pour l'équipe tv m qui ne compte aucun
spécialiste de la montagne dans ses
rangs une journée calme après les
tempêtes les jours derniers
la soirée sera plus tendu
l'antenne de police judiciaire de reims
est là au grand complet assistés de
policiers lyonnais
tous les membres de l'équipe se voit
ordonné de rester à l'hôtel
ce n'est pas un rebondissement de l'anc
est juste un recommencement
lors des débuts de la sphère en mars
dernier certains actes de procédure
n'était pas correct il faut donc en
reprendre une partie les douaniers aussi
poursuivre leur travail
aujourd'hui sur l'autoroute ils ont
contrôlé un camion de l'équipe big mat
et saisi une centaine de médicaments
divers qu'ils vont faire analyser on
arrête pour lui a interdit d'entrer
produit il y avait un très bon aucun
produit visite
moi j'en suis certain c'est que des
produits de jolis de récupération on
sait les produits qui sont seulement et
amiens
donc c'est pour ça je pense qu'ils ont
demandé des contrôles perquisitions à
répétition le thème du dopage ne
quittent décidément pas le tour et les
équipes à commencer par tvm ans sont de
plus en plus excédés les membres de
l'équipe bbm était plutôt soulagé hier
n'ont pas de pré exclu du tour de france
mais il ne s'attendait certainement pas
à avoir à nouveau rendez vous avec les
emplettes
cela dit les auditions d'aujourd'hui ne
signifiait en rien une aggravation de
leur situation les policiers auraient
juste besoin de certaines vérifications
ils sont encore en cours et dans l'
affaire festina enfin le directeur
sportif bruno roussel qui a avoué avoir
organisé un système de dopage au sein de
son équipe a été lui aussi remis en
liberté après 11 jours de détention sol
le médecin de l'équipe le dr rica
demeure puis emprisonné par ailleurs
deux anciens coureurs cyclistes de
l'équipe festina emmanuel magnien gilles
bouvart entendus comme témoins ont
reconnu à leur tour qu'un système de
dopage était organisé au sein de
l'équipe
les obsèques de deux des quatre scouts
mort en mer la semaine dernière en
bretagne ont eu lieu ce matin à
mantes-la-jolie dont il était originaire
l'enterrement ait lieu selon le rite
catholique intégriste et dans la foule
des personnes présentes tout le monde
était d'accord ou presque pour soutenir
l'abbé cottard actuellement en détention
et qu'il n'avait pas reçu l'autorisation
de la justice de venir célébrer cette
fille ce reportage
hervé ghesquière et jean-luc irak
des chants religieux en latin la
communauté catholique traditionaliste de
france a fait ses adieux aux jeunes
scouts morts au large de la bretagne
mercredi dernier hommage à antoine et
damien 13 en hommage à jean-baptiste 16
ans toujours disparus en mer et
solidarité envers le perco tard tenu
pour responsable du drame et emprisonné
à saint brieuc justement simplement
aujourd'hui
pour être fiers de la france fière de
mon pays simplement conquis s'autoriser
l'abbé cottard de guerre à saguenay ce
plaisir les scouts et guides catholiques
regrettait aussi que ce drame ayant
coûté la vie à quatre adolescents et à
un plaisancier tentant de les sauver et
provoqué autant de polémiques
j'ai trouvé qu'on diabolise l affaire
dans le sens où l'on dit voilà ces
disques ou de traduire un aumônier en
soutane vous savez quand les gens voient
à la télévision sur le derrière leur
petit écran il voir un aumônier et qui a
les menottes et qui tout de suite se
font embarquer dans une fourgonnette sa
marque les gens pendant la messe
interdites aux caméras
l'abbé bouchacourt curé de l'église
intégristes de saint nicolas du
chardonnet affirmé dans son sermon que
dieu a accueilli ces adolescents parce
qu'ils étaient prêts et beaucoup dans
l'assistance demander la clémence de la
justice pour le perco tard qui dirigeait
le camp ce que j'espère c'est qu'il sera
qu'on laissera pas en prison soit
vraiment pas qu'est ce qui l'a le de si
grave enfin comment légitimer une telle
incarcération cet après midi les jeunes
scouts ont été inhumé dans la plus
stricte intimité
l'abbé cottard lui ai mis en examen pour
homicides et blessures involontaires par
manquement délibéré aux règles de
sécurité
la sphère de l'infirmière de
mantes-la-jolie accusé d'euthanasie a
choqué ou ému l'opinion publique
française
notre pays l'euthanasie sous toutes ses
formes est rigoureusement interdite aux
pays bas elle est d'ores et déjà
dépénalisé et une loi la règlement entre
est strictement est en préparation
reportage sophie mais elle
hervé poteau dans les couloirs de cet
hôpital à l'abri de ses portes closes on
n'ose plus qu'ailleurs discuter sans
détour de la mort depuis des années les
pays-bas apprennent à dompter le tabou
depuis des années les patients peuvent
parler d'euthanasie parler de leur mort
avec leur médecin traitant afin la chose
la plus importante pour le patient c'est
qu'il sèche peut parler librement et
dedans tout avec son médecin frais
venant y compris de la peur de la
douleur à la proche de la mort par
exemple
en 1994 les pays bas deviennent le pays
d'europe le plus libéral en matière
d'euthanasie
pas étonnant puisque sa population est à
80 % favorables à ce libre choix adoré
ce pacte je respecte les gens qui ont
des principes et qui refusent de décider
de la mort d'un individu
tant que ce n'est pas le choix de dieu
mais personnellement je pense être
capable de prendre mes propres décisions
quand des médecins pratiquent
l'euthanasie sur des personnes gravement
malades
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de problème
aujourd'hui si la pratique de
l'euthanasie est dépénalisé le médecin
vous respecter un protocole d'une
extrême rigueur
le patient doit être incurable sa
douleur doit être insupportable
un second médecin doit nécessairement
donner son avis et enfin enfin le
patient doit lui-même avoir exprimé
clairement de façon insistante et par
écrit son souhait ultime
nombreux sont ceux qui s'y prennent à la
vente dans cette association plus qu'un
soutien psychologique on vient chercher
une aide pour remplir ces formulaires
sorte de testament médicaux trailer ici
on indique les situations quand on veut
plus être traités traitement et si on
indique que les conditions dans
lesquelles on demande d'euthanasie
aujourd'hui les pays bas veulent aller
plus loin un projet de loi va être
discutée dans les semaines les mois à
venir pour cette fois nous qu
dépénaliser
dégâts nous y avons investi du temps et
de l'énergie
mais on peut difficilement envisager
d'exporter vers d'autres pays
la façon que l'on a de traiter ce
problème ici la hollande est il est vrai
réputé pour sa tolérance son respect de
l'autonomie individuelle mais surtout le
poids de l'église y est beaucoup moins
lourd que dans de nombreux autres pays
des 35 heures au banc d'essai la
fédération de la métallurgie négocier
avec des syndicats pour adapter la loi à
ce secteur de l'industrie
l'accord vient d'être signé ce soir avec
force ouvrière la cgc et la cftc les
deux syndicats majoritaires dans ce
secteur mais métallurgie cgt et cbc ont
a priori rejoint david jacquot
emplois-jeunes la sncf mise en place
aujourd'hui dans les gares des brigades
de blouson rouge chargée d'aider les
voyageurs mais aussi de signaler des
problèmes à la police en tout cas
d'éviter les conflits où ils sont 19 en
service à la gare de lyon vous les voyez
bientôt ils seront mille dans toutes les
gares de france l'été la période des
vacances chaque année à pareille époque
les services de la répression des
fraudes contrôle inspectent les
restaurants pour tester la qualité de la
nourriture et son état de fraîcheur ou
de conservation
aujourd'hui c'est en compagnie du
ministre du commerce et d'artisanat que
les inspecteurs ont opéré reportage eric
bastia alice b tu as des glaces à la
vanille pour des touristes anglais on
peut penser qu'elles ne vont pas les
rendre malades et qu'elles ont été
contrôlés en effet marylise lebranchu et
andésite dans ce village touristique
une opération interministérielle de
contrôle de la répression des fraudes
les commerçants ont été prévenus tout a
été organisé entre une opération de
vérification de la bonne information des
acheteurs de faïence et un petit tour
dans un restaurant la ministre a droit
aux compositions des commerçants
je crois qu'il est très intéressant mais
ce serait une
innovation produits et services s'exerce
sur la tromperie l'hygiène alimentaire
et la sécurité durant les quinze
premiers jours de juillet 4600
établissements ont été contrôlés 2002
sans avertissement et 750 poser verbaux
distribués c'est un bon signe qu'un seul
puisque l'on pensait retrouver estelle
sauva plutôt enseigneront depuis que
tout le monde s'est allié pour faire des
contrôles rapproché sur l'ensemble des
départements touristiques
il ya les chiffres sont meilleurs en
matière d'infraction ce qu'on trouve
essentiellement c'est la consommation
licite si les dates limites de
consommation dépassées c'est la
publicité mensongère sur les cartes
c'est à dire encore un restaurateur qui
examinait que produits du pays où
partent mais sans dessert maison est en
fait c'est simplement des produits
congelés également des problèmes
d'hygiène
en début de saison le nombre
d'infractions est toujours plus élevé
que vers la fin
la crainte des contrôles pour ce les
commerçants à veiller au grain sur la
france entière en deux semaines six
tonnes d'aliments ont déjà été détruits
une bonne nouvelle pour trois millions
de familles en france l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire est maintenue cette
année à 1600 francs
si vous correspondez bien entendu au
plafond de ressources retenu le réseau
internet une nouvelle fois mise en
question après la découverte à
montpellier d'un trafic de médicaments
interdits en france car inkomazi thierry
touche à ce reportage
il ya encore deux ans des ampoules telle
que celle ci était autorisée en france
le docteur hugo mendez mésothérapie les
injecter à ses patients souffrant de
lumbago ou désirant lutter contre la
cedh but
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
n'ayant pas été renouvelé ces
médicaments avait tout simplement
disparu de france
du moins c'est ce que le docteur croyait
comme j'ai reçu ce courrier j'étais
assez enthousiaste effectivement et je
me suis renseigné et ses ombres
enseignants auprès de la société que je
me suis aperçu que c'était quand même
une société commerciale et non pas un
laboratoire pharmaceutique ce que
j'avais cru dans un premier temps et
puis la personne n'avait dit que les
produits étaient faits à londres après
j'ai appris par la bande qui s'était
fait en espagne donc ça m'a pas paru
très clair donc j'ai préféré surseoir et
ne pas investir quelques 300 pharmaciens
et médecins dont une centaine en
languedoc roussillon non
hésité à passer commande via cette
adresse internet
les milliers de doses provenant de
barcelone est saisie dans un dépôt de
montpellier concerné surtout le marché
de l'esthétique
parce qu'il ya des intérêts financiers
non puisque les produits qui sont
extrêmement coûteux bien que
l'accumulation de petites sommes des
fois on est très surpris de donner des
sommes importantes
mais c'est surtout peut effectivement se
produit il ya une demande et que à
l'heure actuelle il ya des gens qui sont
prêts à payer pour avoir ces produits
donc il des médecins et des pharmaciens
qui sont prêts à leur procurer pour
répondre à leur désir la direction des
affaires sanitaires et sociales porte
plainte pour exercice illégal de la
pharmacie et infraction à la législation
lagence du médicament doit maintenant
déterminer si ces produits sont nocifs
pour la santé des produits que l'on peut
trouver en vente libre dans les
pharmacies d'andorre à quelques
centaines de kilomètres
une élection législative a recommencé
dans le département du var la députée
socialiste d'être casanova élu au mois
de mai dernier avec seulement 33 voix
d'avancé sur sandrine le chevalier front
national a été annulé
sandrine le chevalier qui à cette
occasion remplaçons m'a remplacé par don
elle son mari député maire de toulon
lui-même invalides le jour même où le
premier ministre a tenu une réunion
importante sur la corse le flnc canal
historique revendique deux attentats
commis récemment dans l'île et sur le
continent
il annonce des actions à venir
l'actualité internationale maintenant au
soudan la guerre entre le gouvernement
et les différentes factions est en passe
d'aboutir à une véritable hécatombe
parmi la population
sept cent mille personnes sont
directement menacés de mort malgré une
opération humanitaire de très grande
ampleur lancée par les nations unies en
effet des centaines de kilos de vivres
ont été larguées sur les régions en
difficulté mais les combattants de tous
bords se servent en premier et la famine
fait aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
victimes chaque jour dans le lyrique
pour les organisations humanitaires
c'est l'urgence au quotidien
oui madame la mère de sept enfants est
ce que quelqu'un peut aller la chercher
pourquoi il n'y a plus rien à faire
120 personnes meurent chaque jour rien
que dans ce village du sud souvent trois
ans en plus unie récolte 15 ans de
guerre ils sont aujourd'hui 700 milles à
lutter pour ne pas mourir jamais rien vu
de pire que les gens appellent à l'aide
et disent on va mourir
allez voir n'importe lequel d'entre eux
ne parle de la mort et même ceux qui
survivront dieu seul sait ce qu'ils
deviendront l'année prochaine s'il n'y a
toujours pas de récolte parce que les
routes sont minés ou impraticables
l'onu a mis en place le plus important
pont aérien de son histoire
dix mille tonnes ont été largués en
juillet il en faudrait deux fois plus et
les ong redoutent une catastrophe
humanitaire
comme en somalie en 92 ou en ethiopie en
80 salles nous pensons que le soudan est
confronté à sa plus grave crise
humanitaire
1989 déjà 250 mines sous d'années ont
perdu la vie à cause de la famine
les rebelles du sud soudan comme les
islamistes de cartes ou utilisent la
famine comme une arme de guerre
les premiers entrave l'aide humanitaire
les autres la détourne pour leurs
soldats
après l'échec de l'opération militaro
humanitaire en somalie
la communauté internationale ne semble
pas prête à intervenir au soudan
situation embarrassante pour le
gouvernement de birmanie depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant bloc sur une
route à la sortie de la capitale rangoon
la voiture de la principale opposante au
régime militaire madame en sang de
circuits prix nobel de la paix qui
tentaient de se rendre dans une ville de
province lorsqu'elle a été bloquée donc
par des militaires sur ce pont où elle
est toujours aujourd'hui on stationne
monica levinsky va pouvoir témoigner
contre le président bill clinton
elle aurait obtenu l'immunité totale de
la part de la justice américaine pour
pouvoir témoigner sur son éventuelle
liaison avec le président amérique en
france lorsqu'on veut monter une milice
ou une sorte d'association de prévention
de sécurité entre locataires ou
propriétaires dans une petite ville ou
dans une région de pavillons et bien
cela pose toujours des tas de problèmes
ce n'est pas du tout le cas en
angleterre là bas une association de
propriétaires de locataires a recueilli
les suffrages de 10 millions d'anglais
qui font partie de ces associations qui
surveille les alentours de leur domicile
et qui au moindre problème est bien font
appel à la police
l'ombre reportage etienne c'est l'heure
de la patrouille ou kanye et bob dans ce
quartier qu'ils connaissent comme leur
poche
tous les deux sont membres de
l'association des broutteux watch les
voisins en alerte
accompagnés de leurs délicieux
rottweiler ils sont reliés par
talkie-walkie alès le vétéran qui se
chargera en cas de problème de prévenir
entre nous on utilise les noms de code
parfois nos prénoms en tout cas jamais
nos noms de famille tous sont bénévoles
dans leur local les serrures et antivol
dernier cri les lampes torches pour les
rondes de nuit la parfaite panoplie
d'une véritable armée secrète où
l'ambiance frise parfois la paranoïa
sécuritaire
on fait des patrouilles trois quatre
fois par semaine toujours à des heures
différentes savary comme ça on a
toujours l'avantagé de la surprise pour
mettre la main sur les malfrats police
n'a plus assez de moyens de personnel
pour venir chaque jour dans nos
quartiers
c'est malheureux mais on est obligé de
le faire à leur place au lycée ministère
de l'intérieur britannique ne cesse
d'ailleurs d'encourager l'association ce
jour-là un ministre délégué s'est
personnellement déplacé dans ce quartier
de londres pour encourager les adhérents
précisant toutefois qu'il n'est pas
question de créer une police parallèle
on pensait organiser des patrouilles
dans leur quartier est carrément se
substituer aux forces de l'ordre
ce n'est pas du tout ça ni baudouin
c'est une entraide entre voisins
depuis sa création en 1982 l'association
ne cesse de s'agrandir
voici sa version rural dans les champs
autour de cambridge là où a priori les
risques de délinquance sont pourtant
moins élevé si on tombe sur quelque
chose de louche on appelle un numéro
central qui ensuite averti tous les
fermiers du voisinage en leur disant
attention un véhicule suspect rouge bleu
ou je ne sais quoi
la vanne à cheval a récemment été volés
grâce à cantu side watch l'information a
été relayée très vite à tous les
fermiers du point en quelques heures
l'un d'entre eux l'a repéré le vans a
été récupéré le voleur a été arrêté
les cambrioleurs sont prévenus
l'association affiche aujourd'hui plus
de 10 millions d'adhérents à travers
tout le pays et d'un britannique sur
cinq ne dort donc que d'un oeil
lutter avec efficacité contre les
trafiquants de drogue exige des pays
concernés qu'ils agissent hors de leurs
frontières les policiers français du
raid assisté des policiers de l'office
des stupéfiants vient des stupéfiants
pardon il vient ainsi de monter une
véritable opération commando contre un
bateau au large des côtes du venezuela
un document exclusif sur les conditions
dans lesquelles s'est déroulée cette
attaque qui a abouti à l'arrestation de
plusieurs dizaines de trafiquants
michel field
ce sont les hommes du raid ont noir sur
le zodiaque qui donnent l'assaut nous
sommes dans les eaux internationales au
large du venezuela selon l'office des
stups français ce voilier le novaïa
était sur le point d'embarquer une
cargaison de 700 kilos de cocaïne en
provenance de colombie et destinée au
marché français à bord les policiers
n'ont pas retrouvé la drogue mais les
deux skippers ont été arrêtés ils
appartiennent à un réseau international
de trafic de stupéfiants seize personnes
en tout ont été interpellées dont les
chefs du réseau
gaby tu es sur la côte d'azur il aura
fallu deux en enquête pour en arriver là
l'enquète ont elles-mêmes oui elle était
particulièrement longue et difficile
parce que ces personnes les personnages
qui est passé dans cette affaire était
en perpétuel mouvement
c'est des gens qui se déplaçait qui se
déplaçait très fréquemment qu'ils
utilisaient des moyens de
télécommunication qui lui est dans les
pays dans lesquels est stationnaire et
en cela ça a été très difficile ça nous
a obligés nous services de police
judiciaire est bien à faire les mêmes
mouvements que lé suivre à la trace
on a essayé de savoir ce qu'ils étaient
en train de mettre au point de planifier
les surveillance en mer auront duré deux
mois pour les stucs français cette
opération baptisée molière était aussi
un test c'est la première fois que les
hommes du raid assisté par la marine
française interpellent des trafiquants
de stupéfiants au large des côtes
internationale est presque cinq tonnes
de cannabis saisies par les douanes voit
l'arrivée le bordeaux la totalité de la
prise a été brûlé il y en avait pour 192
millions de francs à la revente
la juge d'instruction de versailles a
ordonné un non-lieu en faveur d'un
policier auteur d'un coup de feu mortel
sur un jeune de 23 ans à l'occasion d'un
rodéo automobile dans les rues de
mantes-la-jolie c'était en 1991 coups de
feu faisait suite à une fusillade durant
laquelle une jeune femme policier avait
été tué le parquet de versailles fait
appel de cette décision
une affaire d'état à cause d'un concours
de beauté international n'allons pas
trop loin mais l'organisateur anglais du
concours de miss monde refuse la
participation de miss tahiti d'une des
deux
une de miss france au motif que tahiti
ne serait pas vraiment un territoire
français jean bernard schmidt josé
boulesteix c'était déjà le début de la
gloire
élue dauphine de miss france 98 il n'a
noté hanotaux gars alias miss tahiti
était promise à un brillant avenir
représenter la france lors du
traditionnel concours miss monde mais
voilà c'était sans compter la perfide du
britannique et surtout celles de
l'organisateur du concours
eric morlet celui ci refuse la
candidature de miss tahiti motifs tahiti
ce n'est pas la france mais élégant il
n'oublie pas d'encaisser les 30 mille
francs de droits d'inscription nous
sommes libres d'envoyer qui nous voulons
comprendre internationaux du moment que
la jeune fille est française comme une
carte d'identité française que n'en
déplaise à monsieur noir lequel this
pour partie de la république française
commence alors un ballet diplomatique et
posta protestations de la jeune miss
débouté si je ne suis pas française
beaucoup de polynésiens s'interrogent
maintenant sur leur nationalité non
reconnus carte d'identité de la jeune
fille en main le secrétaire d'état à
l'outre-mer dénonce lui toute idée d'un
modèle physique français lire il y a
espèce de canons de beauté française qui
devrait respecter certains codes moi je
n'admets pas notre pays les plus réelles
c'est ce qui fait sa force sa richesse
son dynamisme et donc tahiti a toute sa
place
pas question donc pour le comité
français de retirer la candidature de
mhi state
n'en déplaise à l'organisateur s'est
elle se rendra aux seychelles en
novembre pour concourir eric morlet n'en
est pas à son coup d'essai à deux
reprises il a déjà tenté de refuser deux
miss françaises originaires des dom tom
comme quoi pour certains britanniques
les guerres coloniales avec la france ne
sont pas forcément permis pour les
vacances il y a les traditionalistes qui
continuent de préférer le soleil la mer
et la plage pour d'autres les vacances
sont synonymes de découverte par exemple
la recherche des plantes comestibles
dans la montagne
étonnant vous allez voir mary pierce
amitié grégoire au final
alors je vais vous montrer une plante
carnivore c'est la grâce est vulgaire le
liquide en fait il a plusieurs fonctions
il attire l'infect ylng lui et il la
digère la bestiole pendant le stage 200
à 300 plants sont étudiés ici en 2000
mètres d'altitude
des vacances studieuses pour ces
touristes qui ont préféré la cueillette
au bronzage sur la plage
cette orchidée c'est dactylo risa my
alice dactylo risa ça veut dire la
racine doit là les tubercules fourchue
et elle se distingue de dactylo risa
maculata qui leur est acheté celles ci
on a ramassera pas car ce sont les
plantes comestibles qui sont récoltées
pendant le stage on découvrira la lignée
great où la réponse qui porte aussi des
noms latins le nom latin et je dirais
plus qu'utile parce que c'est la langue
internationale de la botanique vous
parler un chinois de l'antenne arias
deux idiots cas il sait ce que c'est
d'abord séduit sillage là on va manger
la halle et puis sans casse croûte
ici la berce épluché comme une banane a
le goût sucré de la modernisation
même si on la cour comme le saucisson
pour reconnaître les plantes vont buter
on peut aussi fermé les yeux
il va prendre le mors voilà et tu vas
tripoli tu vas me dire dans quel est ce
que tu as dans la main gauche selon ma
voix à gauche qui n'a au malawi et les
beignets de tussilage demande beaucoup
d'attention
il ne faut pas les faire trop frileux
suivra une préparation yaourt glacé aux
pousses déficient
ainsi que des tartines de ciboulette
sauvage al yom
skins oprah's sommes chaque jour une
cueillette différente avec le soleil on
ramassera devoir faire un sorbet avec
des fruits des fruits de quoi déjà des
fruits de miro d'europe
j'ai découvert ou redécouvert comme le
chénopode c'est à dire le pinard et des
légumes que j'ai envie d'apprêter pour
ramener une pointe des diversions dents
mais mu voici donc le garde-manger où
vous pourrez cueillir pour le velouté de
bissorte et d'oseille des alpages ou la
soupe de rumex on en oublie baptême
aujourd'hui à cherbourg du nouveau
bateau de marc thiercelin deuxième du
dernier vendée globe
un monocoque de 18 mètres dont le
parrain est l'acteur lambert wilson
inauguration aujourd'hui dans le port de
cherbourg après la finale manquée du
brésil contre la france lors de la
dernière coupe du monde football
l'entraîneur zagallo s'est vu déchargé
de ses fonctions ont plus de 60 ans il
quitte donc la sélection nationale après
quatre titres même de champion du monde
dont un en tant que joueur de l'équipe
du brésil
eric cantona lui a définitivement quitté
les stades pour se lancer dans le cinéma
il tourne en ce moment dans la région
lyonnaise un film intitulé les enfants
du marais je ne connais pas l'histoire
personne ne la connaît pour le moment
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il fait équipe
avec michel serrault et jacques villeret
avec comme entraîneur ou plutôt
réalisateur jean becker stéphane haumant
jean yves blanc
aujourd'hui quand eric cantona fait son
footing c'est rien du cinéma l'ancien
international attaque une nouvelle
carrière
mais jouer au ballon ou jouer la comédie
finalement c'est toujours faire le
spectacle dans ce film eric the king n'a
qu'un rôle secondaire
mais il est encore une star pas un mot à
la presse consignes de son agent pour
les enfants du marais le voici costumés
années 30
l'enfant terrible du foot a même dû
mettre à sac un café pour les besoins du
script mais dans ce petit village du
beaujolais
l'ex vedette du manchester united a
toujours ses supporters s'il est aussi
forte sur le terrain que directeur je
pense que peut faire des malheurs bas se
trouvaient personne pas parce que j'ai
même réussi à le faire gratuitement
marine j'aurais bien voulu être à sa
place c'est moi qui avais l'appareil oui
j'ai joué dans ces matchs et puis j'aime
bien son caractère en plus pas très
facile mais j'aime bien ce genre gore
contout c'est bien beau mais il ya le
reste de l'équipe
villeret gamblin 0 et du soulier qui
s'amusent où on est les champions
elle était née plus meurtrier mais
nostalgique dans le nouveau film de jean
becker les enfants du marais chronique
sur les petits bonheurs du temps passé
le bonheur est dans le pré et quelques
pubs canto poursuit sa reconversion peut
pas voir beaucoup de métier ou de films
mais je crois que c'est ce que je suis
meilleur à chaque chaîne cfoot chose
parce que le métier des fois c'est un
bol et c'est surtout aussi une
formidable personnalité cet homme là
mais il m'intéressait en panne en europe
au sol pas en tant que footballeur
non mais tant que visage d'antan que 1
peut se dire hey son côté fo va
tous les petits garçons ont rêvé un jour
de devenir footballeur
cantona en a fait son métier mais il
n'était pas tout à fait heureux car son
rêve de gosse à lui c'était faire
l'acteur rien ne se perd vous allez le
voir une entreprise de bordeaux met en
vente un souvenir de la finale de la
coupe du monde de football des fragments
de la pelouse foulée par les joueurs
d'aimé jacquet 120 francs les quelques
brins soigneusement présenté dans un
écrin de plexiglas yannick de solignac
jean pierre baron françois prenez un bon
carré de pelouse bien fraîche bien verte
que 10 au stade de france à saint denis
tondez votre herbe aux dimensions
réglementaires de la fifa découpez la en
petits dés de 4 cm de côté napper là
d'une couche de cristal de synthèse
liquide et vous obtenez une authentique
reliques du mondial la pelouse du stade
de france dans son bloc de verre 5000
exemplaires réalisés pour le compte du
consortium du stade de france fabriqué
dans un petit atelier de bazas cette
fois nous l' aléa la l'époque nous
n'avons reçu et de là où elles viennent
à 0 2 point que certains étaient foulées
en partie ou totalement par l'équipe de
gilles et les autres qui en on l'a reçu
de bonnes le lendemain de la finale elle
est partie et chaque pièce est ensuite
gravées au laser numérotée identifier
elle sera vendue 120 francs dans les
boutiques du stade de france
l'heureux propriétaire pourra toujours
s'imaginer qu'elle a été arrosé de la
sueur de zidane ou des larmes de laurent
blanc
la fin de ce journal je vous rappelle
les principaux titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi accident tragique sur
l'autoroute a7 à un carambolage entre
trois autocars et un poids lourd couché
sur la route qui a fait sept morts
l'un des chauffeurs d'autocars rouler
trouve tour de france réaction d'orgueil
de l'allemand ulrich qui a une étape
d'albertville devant pont d'any qui
reste maillot jaune dopage les policiers
perquisitionnent ce soir l'autel des tv
voilà dans un instant la météo patrice
drevet je vous donne rendez vous demain
à 20h excellente soirée sur notre chef
bonsoir à tous
ça